amanda is with us Amanda's in Oklahoma
hi Amanda how are you hi good how are
you supposed to talk to you you too
what's up
um actually it's me and my husband here
and I'm gonna let him explain the
question since he's a little less
nervous than me okay how are you man
good thank you for taking our call we've
just got a general wisdom question we'd
like to your advice on we are currently
debt-free good well we have a house
that's paid for one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars congratulations thank
you we're kind of getting the house
we've earned we'd like to upgrade a
little bit our big question is is
whether or not we should keep our house
or rent it out if we if we ran our house
out we're not going to have a big down
payment for the next house that we have
then I would sell right but but what we
do have enough money to cover the
expenses of of the new house expenses
mortgage basically oh no no we're not
going to go back into dad you got out of
that no you know we don't we you know
let's say you had the other house and it
was paid for and you called me and said
I want to buy a rental and go into debt
I would tell you know wouldn't I I would
tell you I tell you to pay cash for the
rental effectual in effect that's what
we're doing here you're taking your your
current home and turning it into a
rental thereby going into debt on your
current home you gonna borrow money on
your residence in order to have a
debt-free rental that's the effect of
this math are you seeing what I'm saying
yeah so I would just sell it and use the
hundred and fifty to make your purchase
and you know put as much down as you
possibly can if you can't save up the
difference and pay cash for the move up
then put it in a position where you can
pay it off very very very very quickly
okay the other concern that we have is
our current home needs probably about
ten to fifteen thousand dollars worth of
repair before we sell it what's your
household income about a hundred
thousand a year we'll just cash flow it
okay none of your payment's so tell us
basically telling us to wait a little
while
you pay cash you're not gonna call Dave
Ramsey until you go into that right okay
you know it's not gonna happen because I
believe the best way to have a great
life and to build wealth and to help
others is to be debt-free I really
believe that and so I'm gonna lead you
I'm not gonna ever lead you back into
debt and if you know even if I stand
back and hold my nose and say on this
other house you're gonna go into that a
little bit then at least you know at
least put it in a position where you pay
it off very very quickly like I'm
talking like three years or something
you know put this thing I got car
payment and be done with it really
really really fast you make really good
money calm down
don't you know impatience is what drives
a lot of people into that on anything
they're doing I just don't wait to save
up to pay for it and I want to help you
avoid that hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the same
room the channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you